what is your advice for somebody that in
a company that they take down a fan
internet minded culture
death by peter giants there your
channel implants
the also know control barbecue control
in o 21 mindset agree that's
something like and push break it
influence and  take care of the people the
left or less the rider along if you
take care of the people i work for me
he walked a take care the person iwork
for some times me even toxic
boss snap i is there at the focus means
the standing pressure  other
sometimes the symbolic the mpv thor
boss in europe boss you really harness
two way row or column
nice the watcher and here that mieke week
a sexy together we help you in your
front where my entire
organization
leadership is to the bar rancraft ardie
leadership  is taking responsibility for
people renders
and such a new and new marian and not
no millennium single and in limbo kbo
because of this
the first choice is that love want a b d
f and the mi  jn en en journal george climb
of a recordset the firth creature in
the bene league euro jihad donahue en zo
ne football in chernobyl liter and that's
what you want so how do i get there to sing
the people go green work on a daily
base is not coming  to work
the philips to us that often the phils are
on the guild de has hardcover
defiant cimetière date you say my
legs are silent and listen story and luis
and to offer yourself who kibera leader off to
a great start ics-1000 teams started
wheelie high  performing jeans start
super crazy and you start ego flower there she
class knvb team our internet chinese
cabbage direction to work and
before you know all those people go she
had another theme no t kevin in
we encourage save and I dare after  13
a pharmacy in it of the mindset and
the whole work functions there
within the software so there is cia
after which the sable coast
seagulls avenue last we have his
charger just the goal how to do so
for the google biorit  me are no orders
for the dared crows and the whole workday
and
[Music]
a
and
and now